the girag and experience what's hard for
people to grasp is that you don't know
what's next that's hard
it's scary it freaks people out so they
seek they seek help pills booze bullshit
bad relationships and drama at work and
all this nonsense you're just filling up
your stupid head with just distract
yourself from this ultimate fascinating
existence that we find ourselves in
where we kill we have no idea what's
coming next we don't know what's going
on right now anywhere except what's
right in front of us and even then the
wheels of perception they eat and flow
depending on what chemicals you've
induced into your body or they're not a
smoke to join or ate a mushroom or you
know there's a lot going on here it's
not just as simple as this flat
consciousness that we all agree upon
because I'm not entirely sure that other
people have the same experience that I
do when I look at like some country
music and I look at like some TV shows
and I looked at some music country music
a lot of pop music I actually probably
liked more country music now than I even
like hot music we spent some good times
in a country yeah I'm a big white Yocum
fan I like my dog's name Johnny Cash and
I like cut some country music but
there's some really stupid shit out
there why is it is it because they're
dumber than me or they see in a
different reality is reality just like
your nose like your nose is a nose my
nose nose but if my nose was on your
face I'd be like what did you do
different you did something different
and if you put your nose on my face you
be like do some go on your nose looks
different or something it would be we
both have a nose it's very recognizable
neither one are distinct there's there's
nothing you know like we don't flatten
boxers noses or anything they're both
pretty normal but I know my nose and I
know your nose and I know your nose is
in my nose how do I know that that's not
like reality that reality like with what
other people see they're seeing it
through a filter that makes things that
suck come in at come out there bit a
better shape they have it has a better
smell to it
things that seem stupid to you to them
it all just fits right into this neuron
and this this look this ability to
interact with light accepts this shape
better than that shit
for some strange with orange it's always
been my favorite color are you seeing
the same color I am because orange looks
stupid
how do you like orange yeah I want an
orange car you fucking weirdo yeah wish
you know what I mean it's like what why
would you like orange is it is it is it
a taste thing or is it a taste thing and
your world is different than mine I
think what you're mentioning is really
one of the key lessons that does mention
is pot smoking nonsense that's what I
mean well I was just yelling when I was
on that when I did my my last ayahuasca
trip in Peru and I had the vision of the
eagle and that was the secret that he
basically gave me is up flying along
with this condor eagle and the eagle
says to me you know you want to know how
to see better you see through everybody
else's eyes and the message there was
that everybody has their own perception
and to really understand what you're
going through what they're going through
and seeing you have to see what they see
through their lens of perception and if
you can do that you know all a lot of
this hate and a lot of this anger goes
away what you feel instead can be maybe
pity button I feel bad for this human
look at the way the world appears to
them look at the way you know that
person is so quick to anger so quick to
hate when really you know they could
look at the same situation with love and
feel happiness and so it shifts your
kind of opinion on things but no doubt
about it we look at things a different
way and the recent studies on
epigenetics will show that you know
things you can change the way things
appear probably not only on a mental
level but probably a genetic level based
on your epigenetic manipulation of
belief you know and in what you see and
I think you know Bruce Lipton's doing a
lot of good research in that and that's
a really exciting field but you know
just because you have a certain lens of
perception doesn't mean that that can't
change with your choices and with your
belief yeah and that that change would
help you we want to we want to hang on
to the way we are so badly we don't want
to admit that we were wrong if we met
wherever wrong then we have this
reevaluation of the value of self
because the value of self is very
important and one of the important
things a lot of people have is that
they're right they want to be right
like a lot of you times you get
an argument with someone and it a
certain point that you're like why are
we even why am I upset about this like I
have nothing to do with this lizard that
lives in fucking the Komodo Islands I
have nothing to do with them but you're
insisting that it lives all over the
place and I'm telling you it only lives
there and it fucking zoos and like why
is this even why is this upsetting what
is it about this what's really going on
here people um we develop patterns you
know in attachments no in attachments -
you're attached to the persona of the
guy who's right about random facts you
know so when you're attached to that and
it gets challenged you identify with it
that's part of you so it's actually
threatening a piece of you which
triggers the kind of fear mechanism is
it's fascinating we talked to someone
and you mean I I would never say that
I'm absolutely free of that I'm not free
of any human emotion norsu but I'm
pretty good at controlling that impulse
and I'm also pretty good at not being
attached to ideas until I've like really
extremely vetted them out and also
vetted out the opposing idea but I've
had conversations with people where they
say something me like I had a
conversation with this kid where he was
talking about psychedelic mushrooms and
he disagreed that he was like very
adamant very smart kid very young
probably like maybe 20 and he was
talking to me about how you know I
disagree with terence mckenna's stoned
mushroom theory he goes I think it's too
simplistic and it ignores the fact that
there's so many different strange things
that are uber complex all throughout the
universe
you know why why should we assume that
human beings got this way because of one
compound and I was like you're right
fuck do I know why I don't know nothing
about and he was like he goes okay I can
respect that I go yeah I mean what did I
do the research am i I don't know I
think it's a good idea I think the idea
is sound because I think the chimps
obviously they think and mushrooms make
me think in a completely unique way and
I think that if a chimp ate mushrooms
you'll probably affect the way Thanks I
mean just seems to make sense - no doubt
I mean you can see it I mean you look at
you look at the pictures of the dolphins
who were just doing the fucking the
puffer fish toxin they're going to the
surface and looking at their reflection
you know at that at that point that has
to be changing some of the
usual usual pattern is probably fine
fresh fine fish let's find fish although
its place are fuck let's a flower
let's find fish more fun and then all
the sudden they stop all that and it
quiets they say wow look at me I'm a
fucking dolphin and then and then it's a
different pathway that opens up and
that's what happened in these monkeys
too at a certain point or humanoids or
whatever what stage they were on a
certain point they're like whoo yeah